[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans dimanche en
politique la politique elle est faite de
coup de théâtre la réforme de retraite
en est une illustration toute vue être
mis sur la table là en décembre et puis
changement de tempo ce sera en janvier
reste ce qu'il va falloir convaincre les
Français une fois la Coupe du monde de
football passée d'autant que les
préoccupations autour du pouvoir d'achat
du coup de l'énergie sont toujours aussi
vives elles étaient déjà en toile de
fond il y a quelques mois lors de la
campagne présidentielle notre invité
aujourd'hui est le président du MoDem
François Bayrou bonjour vous êtes aussi
au commissaire au Plan secrétaire
général du Conseil national de la
refondation et maire de Pau j'ajoute
toujours parce que vous êtes beaucoup
jamais apo on joue au rugby alors ce
sera l'année prochaine la Coupe du monde
de rugby en France faudra attendre qu'on
joue aussi au football on joue au basket
on joue au handball on va parler de
football la France sera peut-être
championne du monde de football le ciel
gagne au Qatar tout à l'heure face à
l'Argentine pourrait Emmanuel Macron le
Qatar a très bien organisé les choses
est-ce que c'est ce que vous retiendriez
oui
je suis sûr que beaucoup de
téléspectateurs comme moi
ont été
surpris
impressionné par la qualité des
installations
et on a vu du point de vue des
spectateurs on a vu que le football
on n'a pas vu la toile de fond
l'arrière-plan qui probablement est
sujet à discussion polémique mais ce qui
a ce qui a frappé c'est la qualité des
installations alors vous parlez de la
toile Japon il y a deux semaines a été
révélé une affaire de peau de vin versée
à des députés européens et notamment à
la vice-présidente du Parlement européen
par le Qatar pour qu'il soit les relais
du Qatar au niveau européen êtes-vous
surpris par ces révélations
franchement oui chaque fois que des
responsables politiques se laissent
aller à la lettre corrompu ce qu'il faut
appeler les choses par leur nom c'est de
la corruption c'est de la corruption
contre
espèce sonore et trébuchantes comme on
disait en français autrefois elle a
plutôt des billets
oui franchement parce que je
n'imagine pas que
on puisse
à ce point négligé méprisé son devoir
les valeurs auxquelles on croit c'est le
groupe socialiste du Parlement européen
franchement je ne l'aurais pas cru je ne
dis pas que d'autres groupes ne sont pas
eux aussi menacés de révélation
je ne dis pas qu'il ne faillit pas
renforcer tout ça mais franchement que
des que des
responsable politique qui sont
en premier lieu des militants qui
croient en quelque chose qui s'engage
parce qu'ils veulent changer le monde
accepte comme ça de se faire acheter
c'est pas la première fois dans
l'histoire mais chaque fois pour moi
c'est une surprise ça peut entacher tout
le Parlement européen ou c'est seulement
circonscrit un groupe parlementaire les
socialistes vous disiez tout à l'heure
oui je
suis pas sûr que tout le monde soit à
l'abri
parce que vous voyez bien qu'il y a là
quelque chose
qui s'apparente à une entreprise de
d'influence de prise de contrôle de la
part du Qatar avec de la part du Qatar
et de et on ne sait pas d'autres
mais c'est en effet quelque chose qui
touche
à la démocratie européenne on est très
fier de on est le seul continent
qui est à ce point privilégié des règles
démocratiques et une confiance
et qu'on puisse ainsi fouler au pied les
raisons de notre engagement collectif
c'est pour moi c'est très choquant un
mot sur le Qatar en France parce que le
Qatar les investisseurs
qatari en France bénéficient d'un statut
fiscal à part qui leur permet de de ne
pas payer par exemple d'impôts sur les
biens immobiliers quand il y a des
reventes par exemple ça c'est une qui
date de 2008
Emmanuel Macron en 2017 avait dit en
2017 avait dit il faudra revoir ça ça
n'est pas normal vous l'aviez dit aussi
c'est resté d'être morte est-ce qu'il
faut relancer l'idée
j'ai toujours trouvé que ce type de
statut
dérogatoire
au principe qu'on impose à tout le monde
normalement tous les investisseurs en
France tous les agents économiques comme
on dit sont soumis au même règle
fiscales c'est même un principe
constitutionnel est-ce qu'il faut
remettre ça sur le tapis de toute façon
les gouvernements seront obligés de le
faire parce que l'opinion publique veut
cette égalité des chances et elle a bien
raison vous savez le la France est
probablement le pays dans le monde où le
principe d'égalité est le plus respecté
et le plus exigé à part et je suis
persuadé que que ça se fera je ne sais
pas quelle évolution il y a eu depuis
que Nicolas Sarkozy en 2008 à imposé ce
statut pour moi en tout cas c'est pas
normal la Coupe du monde ne sera
probablement pas le seul sujet de
conversation à table pour les fêtes de
fin d'année dans quelques jours il y
aura forcément les retraites mais aussi
la pénurie de médicaments
les états paru pertinents de décaler de
quelques jours ou quelques petites
semaines l'annonce de la finalisation de
la proposition du gouvernement et donc
au lieu d'opter pour le 15 décembre me
font ça le 10 janvier repouss
er le thé vous avez peur et vous avez
raison d'avoir peur c'est non à cette
réforme injuste brutale nous sommes tous
unis pour dire NON toute façon 65 ou 64
+ allongement de la durée des
cotisations c'est du pareil au même on
va travailler plus longtemps on est
opposé au recul de l'âge légal de départ
en retraite il faut à mon sens que les
que les LR se
conforme aux engagements qu'ils ont pris
devant les Français il faut faire une
réforme mais pas n'importe laquelle pas
n'importe comment pas avec de la
brutalité et en évitant la provocation
antibiotique antalgique
anti-inflammatoire tous les médicaments
sont concernés à l'heure des fêtes de
Noël il est incongru de penser que le
plus beau des cadeaux que l'on puisse
faire à des parents est une boîte de
doliprane pour enfants la mobilisation
du gouvernement est totale dans le cas
de plan du plan France 2030 porté par le
gouvernement va nous amener
progressivement à rapatrier les
principes actifs les plus importants en
particulier de l'iprane de l'année
prochaine on peut tenir combien de jours
avec
avec ça on peut tenir avec ça très peu
de jours on en a pour trois jours
François Bayrou on va commencer par les
retraites finalement ce sera le 10
janvier qui Élisabeth borne dévoilera
les grandes lignes de la réforme du
gouvernement il reste trois semaines
pour changer tout qu'est-ce que vous
croyez pouvoir faire est-ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement va pouvoir
fissurer le front du refus qu'on vient
de voir
si vous permettez ça n'est pas la
première question à poser on va revenir
sur le fond tout à l'heure mais pour
nous d'abord première
considération
et première certitude
la réforme des retraites est
indispensable pour la survie du régime
des retraites le système de retraite
français dans l'état actuel
d'organisation comme vous savez nous
avons édité une note de du Haut
Commissariat aux plans sur l'état réel
enfin les chiffres de l'équilibre
financier du système de retraite et ce
qui apparaît c'est que au contraire de
ce qu'on disait de ce qui était si
souvent affirmé
et que croyait beaucoup de bons esprits
beaucoup d'amis me disaient mais
François il y a pas besoin de réforme de
système de retraites en tout cas c'est
pas urgent parce que parce que c'est
équilibré et même cet excédentaire
disait-on en réalité il y a 30 milliards
de déficit du système de retraite qui
sont pris en charge par l'argent
on s'arrête une seconde mais vraiment
une 30 milliards c'est 30 000 millions
d'euros
c'est je vois
cette interrogation
et c'est plus que le budget de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche est-ce que vous croyez que
vous allez pouvoir
fissurer le front du refus qu'on vient
de voir là moi je crois aux citoyens je
crois moins aux organisations
concitoyens je pense que si les Français
mesurent se rendent compte
[Musique]
du péril dans lequel nous sommes de la
de la menace devant laquelle nous sommes
et qui est une menace qui fait que ou
qui ferait que si on ne fait rien on
pourrait plus payer les retraites d'ici
quelques années et que si on ne fait
rien le déficit du pays va exploser
parce que parce que les parce que les 30
milliards qui sont prises en charge par
le budget de l'État pour équilibrer le
système des retraites c'est 30 milliards
là c'est du déficit et de la dette mais
vous dites
que nous sommes en situation de
déséquilibre j'entends ce que vous dites
vous croyez
mais je vous les mais maintenant juste
je crois plus aux Français ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'en cas de blocages
il faudrait avoir recours au référendum
comme vous l'aviez dit il y a quelques
mois
j'avais toujours défendu cette idée mais
je veux pas me situer ni au gouvernement
ni au président
je n'écarte rien je dis seulement que
vous dites le fond du refus les
organisations qui disent non
en leur fort intérieur les responsables
de ces organisations savent
qu'il faut absolument qu'on fasse
quelque chose alors justement on va dire
sur le détail la preuve ces
organisations elles sont toutes parties
prenantes d'un système de retraite qui
s'appelle agirco et qui est entre les
mains des partenaires sociaux et agir
arco est en équilibre et chaque fois que
des décisions ont dû être prises pour
que ce régime
retrouve son équilibre soit assuré de
son équilibre elles ont été prises par
les partenaires sociaux par les
syndicats en l'occurrence par les
syndicats par les partenaires sociaux
par les syndicats et
l'ensemble
sur le référendum vous dites vous
n'excusez pas en dernier recours moi je
n'ai jamais exclu le référendum j'ai
toujours été
persuadé que lorsqu'on se trouve en
situation de blocage lorsque quelque
chose d'essentiel pour le pays est en
jeu
les institutions ont prévu un juge de
paix et ce juge de paix c'est évidemment
à lever c'est une parce que si on fait
le travail de persuasion nécessaire
j'aime pas trop le mode pédagogie je
l'emploi quelquefois c'est vous qui le
disez mais parce que pédagogie
voilà ça s'adresse à des à des à des
élèves
étymologiquement là c'est un travail de
persuasion civile c'est un des citoyens
qu'on s'adresse alors justement eux ils
veulent savoir est-ce qu'on partira à 64
ans et quelques mois de cotisations en
plus ou à 65 ans où va votre préférence
du modèle ce débat là est formidable
parce que et il est entretenu par tout
le monde de bonne foi comme s'il
s'agissait d'une décision pour demain
matin pour le pour le mois de mars ou
pour le mois de juillet c'est ce que
veulent faire Emmanuel Macron
à ce piège là vous êtes pris
64 ans âge légal du départ à la retraite
ou 65 ans ou quelques mois de cotisation
en plus ça n'est pas pour juillet ça
n'est pas pour l'année 2023 c'est pour
dans 10 ans j'entends mais il faut que
la gloire
de la République oui non mais on peut
voter une loi et on va en parler
votre préférence à vous 64 ans 65 ans
je suis pour qu'on puisse trouver un
accord donc parce que entre 64 ans avec
des mois de cotisation en plus et 65 ans
100 mois de cotisation en plus je suis
pas sûr que la différence soit abyssale
donc
entre les deux non 34 ans il y a
un élément précis qui va dans ce sens où
qui peut être mise en compte c'est que
le Sénat a voté
très largement 64 ans cette réforme là à
64 ans
avec un allongement du cotisations donc
on peut réfléchir je suis persuadé qui
est ouverte je suis persuadé pour moi
oui je suis persuadé qu'il n'y a pas de
réforme des retraites sans que
l'ensemble des acteurs ou des
responsables face un pas les uns vers
les autres c'est pourquoi
le chemin peut-être c'est pourquoi je ne
crois pas à une réforme à décision
unique je ne crois pas à la seule
question de l'âge
je pense qu'il faut un ensemble de
décisions et de mesure un ensemble à
mixte comme on dit un mélange de
décision qui permettent de trouver un
accord alors il y a une proposition que
vous faites qui n'est pas reprise par le
gouvernement vous proposez d'augmenter
les cotisations patronales de 1% qui
rapporterait 7 milliards et demi le mot
d'ordre au gouvernement c'est pas
d'augmentation des impôts il y a peu de
chances que ça soit dans le texte final
le gouvernement
n'a pas retenu cette option vous le
regrettez non on va voir
vous comprenez tout le monde fait comme
si l'annonce qui sera faite le 10
janvier
cette annonce là mettez un terme au
débat et ça n'est pas vrai le 10 janvier
le débat commence et les parlementaires
et les forces sociales et les
observateurs les acteurs les experts
tout le monde va essayer d'enrichir ce
texte et je trouve que c'est bien et
c'est peut-être le début aussi de
beaucoup de monde dans les rues oui
c'est possible là mais encore une fois
si vous avez écouté les nuances entre
les différentes expressions que vous
avez passé sur votre écran c'est nuances
existent elles montrent qu'il y a une
pluralité de position
chacun a une posture de départ
chacun
montre un visage
en ayant à l'idée que peut-être les
choses évolueront en tout cas moi je le
crois quel est le quelle est la question
moi j'appartiens au grand courant
réformiste du pays
ceux qui croient il y en a parmi les
syndicats il y en a parmi les partis
politiques ceux qui croient ceux qui
croient
un certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales vous le par exemple la CFDT
par exemple la CFTC par exemple le
traditionnellement
des organisations syndicales et
patronales qui ont à l'esprit que
lorsqu'un pays a besoin de changement ce
changement on peut le faire de manière
progressive en respectant les opinions
des autres qu'on n'est pas obligé de
tout mettre par terre que n'est pas
obligé de faire la révolution chaque
fois qu'on doit changer quelque chose
j'ai entendu et qui pense cela que la
révolution parfois elle peut être aussi
extrêmement critique pour un pays on
peut discuter avec eux ce que voulait
dire avec le Modem en tout cas vous êtes
un allié incontournable de la majorité
mais aussi au plan ou au Conseil
national de la Fondation votre porte
également
pas de boule de cristal dans le bureau
de François Bayrou au commissaire au
Plan j'ajouterai un chapitre à la note
parce que je plaide pour un nouveau type
de logement ici il s'agit de voir loin
20 ou 30 ans et si le général est
visionnaire les troupes sont réduites
cette toute petite unité c'est un
commando il y a cinq ou six personnes
mais efficaces sa proximité avec
Emmanuel Macron c'est l'histoire d'un
ralliement 2017 depuis il n'est jamais
très loin conseiller du président patron
du MoDem au commissaire au Plan et
depuis deux mois cheville ouvrière du
Conseil national de la refondation le
nouvel outil pour faciliter les réformes
tout le monde était une année pour dire
c'est utile c'est bien c'est positif
compter à Paris mais peser à Pau c'est
de cet ancrage local qui tire avantage
et quand le garde des sceaux inaugure la
cité judiciaire le maire de Pau réclame
déjà la prison l'air de rien
c'est une mise en route le fera
peut-être aussi pour l'établissement
pénitentiaire que nous avons
à Paris la majorité présidentielle elle
est fragile alors quelle potion magique
pour rassembler c'est du citron
bouillant avec du miel
non non pour l'énergie et quel rôle pour
l'Allier des premiers jours qui
s'intéresse à l'astrologie pourrait sans
doute conclure que je suis gémeaux
ascendant balance
[Musique]
qui fait comme une complexité non
central et pour 2027 les cartes du ciel
et le reste très floues vous aviez prévu
un autre destin
oui mais d'abord le temps est long
et on va aller directement le Conseil
national de la refondation il est
destiné à faire participer les Français
à les réflexions sur les enjeux de la
France pour l'avenir dans le même temps
on voit qu'Elizabeth borne multiplie les
49-3 notamment le dernier pour le budget
le dixième pour faire passer le budget
en l'occurrence est-ce que c'est pas
contradictoire non
le 49-3 c'est une une arme
institutionnelle nous dit institutionnel
qui existe dans notre législation et
plus précisément dans notre Constitution
c'est pas contradictoire avec je vais
essayer de vous expliquer rapidement au
Parlement
quand vous n'avez pas de majorité soit
vous acceptez que les textes soient
bloqués éternellement soit vous avez cet
instrument qui dit
on est d'accord vous êtes pas d'accord
avec le texte qu'on propose mais pour
nous ce texte est essentiel donc on le
et si vous ne nous renversez pas le
texte
considéré comme quoi à la tribune de
l'Assemblée Elizabeth borne a reconnu
quand même que faire passer le budget
avec 10 49,3 c'est pas la bonne solution
elle l'a dit elle-même ça veut donc dire
que ça exclut 49-3 pour l'avenir
notamment sur les retraites
je pense que c'est une arme légitime
d'abord sur les retraites peut-être
il faut rappeler que les institutions
font qu'il n'y a parc session qu'un 49-3
autorisé
que cette arme ne peut être utilisée
qu'une seule fois en dehors des textes
budgétaires et oui mais ça pourrait
passer dans un texte budgétaire ce
serait une erreur
la chose importante pour moi c'est que
le débat est lieu
comprennent le temps nécessaire pour le
débat sauf que présente la République a
dit il faut que ce soit voté à l'été ça
tiendra dans le calendrier on a tout le
temps vous croyez que ça tiendra oui
parce que imaginez que nous passions
plusieurs semaines à discuter le texte
si vous croyez que tous les arguments
n'auront pas été avancés et utilisés
bien sûr qu'on connaîtra tous les
arguments et donc cette cette
organisation des pouvoirs publics
français je vous rappelle que Michel
Rocard a dû utiliser le 49-3 c'est pas
28 fois
on n'est pas en position de force il y a
pas de majorité absolue et les Français
d'une certaine manière l'ont voulu alors
élus le président de la République ils
ont dit mais on va alors équilibrer un
peu les choses
du service politique de France Télé qui
est avec nous ce midi pour sa carte
blanche
[Musique]
on en parlait là il y a quelques
instants 10 49-3 un budget adopté au
forceps est-ce que vous imaginiez il y a
quelques mois une situation aussi
chaotique politiquement
oui parce que j'ai toujours pensé que la
majorité absolue n'était pas automatique
mais pourtant pas en vérité elle est
lorsqu'on nouveau président est élu là
il y a une vague les choses s'arrangent
mais j'ai vécu des situations dans
lesquelles il y avait pas de majorité
non mais je vous demande ça François
Mitterrand il y avait pas de majorité et
les choses avancées cependant je l'ai
dit pour Michel roc qui avait je vous
demande ça parce que vous disiez dès la
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron que la
priorité c'est la réconciliation civique
oui on en est loin aujourd'hui
oui on allait loin mais peut-être en
étant plus près qui a 6 mois
un très grand nombre de responsables
politiques parlementaire ou exécutif qui
trouve que ce système d'épreuve de force
perpétuelle
d'affrontement qui atteint à l'Assemblée
nationale
un seuil que pour ma part je n'ai jamais
vu atteint la violence des
interpellations le
la perpétuelle mise en accusation
des uns par les autres et des autres par
les uns jamais on a connu ce seuil là
mais j'ai souvent pensé que vous aviez
une responsabilité spécialement vous
France 3 vous avez une responsabilité
parce que si
vous n'aviez pas ce dispositif très futé
qui consiste à couper les micro de
l'hémicycle mais à
devenir seulement le micro de diffuser
sur France 3 d'ailleurs
c'est un tort et donc comme vous avez
été pendant des années revenir
[Musique]
ça a l'air d'une plaisanterie c'est tout
à fait sérieux si les Français
entendaient le le réellement la violence
du climat et des interpellations qui
existent dans l'hémicycle il ne
tolérerait pas
sur France 3 vous parlez d'affrontement
est-ce qu'on peut penser aussi que au
sein même de la majorité vous vous
souvenez vous vous appeliez ensemble
pendant la campagne aujourd'hui on a
plus l'impression que vous êtes ensemble
puisque chacun fait entendre sa voix que
ce soit Édouard Philippe pour horizon
vous-même pour le modem ou renaissant ou
Renaissance est-ce que vous ne partagez
pas du tout votre sentiment sur les
retraites on a vu qu'il y avait
différents lignes quand même mais
attendez les retraites heureusement
qu'on va pouvoir s'exprimer pendant le
débat
parce que sans ça vous accuseriez
à juste titre de de
d'impérialisme de surdité de non on va
pouvoir s'exprimer et c'est normal de
s'exprimer mais j'ai connu beaucoup de
majorité je n'en ai pas connu qui soit
aussi solidaire que celle-là après
il y a des sensibilités différentes et
des voies différentes à l'intérieur même
de renaissance
les sensibilités ne sont pas exactement
les mêmes et c'est normal et c'est pas
grave alors que ces derniers questions
c'est le dernier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que l'après pourquoi pas
ah bon
c'est
les institutions font que le Président
de la République quand il a fait demanda
ne peut pas se représenter pour le
mandat suivant donc vous vous plaidez
il aura pas 50 ans lorsque son mandat
s'avéra et pour moi
les responsables politiques majeurs ceux
qui ont su saisir une partie de
l'histoire du pays
si ça les intéresse et je crois que ça
l'intéresse il continue à jouer un rôle
dans l'histoire du pays vous nous dites
que en 2027 il ne pourra pas se
représenter mais s'il a envie de se
représenter en 2032 il en a tout à fait
le droit par la Constitution vous le
souhaiteriez je suis pas en 2032 on sait
pas on en sait pas
où on en sera en 2032 et c'est
considérationsoiseuses qui sont
perpétuellement répétés dans le monde
médiatique à propos de à propos de cette
succession d'élections me paraissent pas
pour l'instant très sérieuse de Mia 32
on en reparlera je vous promets quand on
y sent comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous
savez il avait utilisé cette phrase
qu'il pourrait se mettre en retrait sans
être en retraite est-ce que c'est votre
volonté aussi dans les prochains mois
donc je suis
quelqu'un qui croit que la citoyenneté
est une citoyenneté de pleine
responsabilité qu'on la met pas entre
parenthèses qu'on continue à occuper les
responsabilités que les Français vous
confient après il y a des organisations
différentes mais c'est le rythme
démocratique
vous ne passerez pas la main tout de
suite alors
œdème à la tête du MoDem ça je déciderai
moi-même lors du prochain congrès
qu'elle sera ma position elle est pas
prise de décision
merci Cyril merci François bayrouleur
accepté notre invitation dans dimanche
en public et je remercie aussi notre
équipe fidèle Tristan donna la
réalisation claire et Sébastien la
rédaction chef et Valérie Verduron à
l'édition merci à tous les invités qui
sont venus sur ce plateau au cours de
l'année 2022 qui a été une année
présidentielle alors on verra ce que
nous réserve 2023 bien évidemment je
vous donne rendez-vous le 8 janvier tout
de suite David Baudry pour l'actualité
de la journée
[Musique]